et pour en parler nous sommes avec
stephen witkowski merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur st fons stéphane et sophie
spécialiste de que de cuba clairement
peut-on dire que c'est la fin d'une
époque
je dirais que c'est une date symbolique
mais qui étaient déjà préparés de très
longue date puisque en réalité
mediascan elle qui a pris le premier
secrétariat du parti et avait été déjà
été président du conseil d'état en 2018
il avait été élu président la république
en 2019 et étant déjà en fonction depuis
trois ans et ce processus est une
processus de transition générationnelle
mais d'aucune manière une transition
politique car il y avait aussi une
réforme de la nouvelle constitution qui
avaient été validées par les cubains qui
avaient été amendés discuté par les
cubains avant 2019 et qui avait un peu
modifié l'équilibré institutionnel et
politique
donc c'est une nouvelle date je dirais
symboliquement importante pour raul
castro lui-même et qui était déjà encore
une fois prévu mais qui s'inscrit
lorsqu'on appelle le
l'institutionnalisation de la révolution
et donc les des objectifs de la
révolution de moeurs il ya pas
changement sur ce plan est en revanche
je dirais que la feuille de route qui a
été clairement indiquée par raul castro
lors de son discours il ya deux jours
définit surtout des objectifs
économiques et sociaux extrêmement
important et en maintenant le cap par
rapport à les fils défi majeur qui est
la relation avec les états unis
les défis les plus importants c'est
d'abord le l'unification ou monétaires
qui a été déjà été initiée depuis le 1er
janvier et qui est un défi qui posent
des questions à la fois technique
sociétaux et politiques
il ya un deuxième objectif économique
important c'est de réduire
david dépendance agro alimentaire et
énergétique de l'île qui très dépendants
de l'étranger
et puis ici il ya évidemment d'autres
défis un peu plus de moyenne en terme
d'aidé fils démographique puisque la
société cubaine est de plus en plus âgée
et c'est la contrepartie d'une de la
qualité d'une médecine qui est
importante et l'informatisation de la
société acquis sur lequel l'actuel
président a mis l'accent pour vraiment
informatisé la société d'autant que
c'est un ingénieur de formation et il
souhaite effectivement que la société
cubaine soit 13 informatisé alors la
contrepartie c'est effectivement ce que
dit votre documentaire c'est que il ya
effectivement une société civile qui est
de plus en plus éveillés informé
instruite de toute façon parce qu'il ya
un très haut niveau de formation à la
cuba mais évidemment cette société en
particulier cette génération des 20 45
ans à peu près qui a un très haut niveau
de formation et qui souhaiteraient avoir
des débouchés professionnels et des
salaires et qui correspondent à leurs à
leur formation est effectivement
pardonner ces défis c'est président
actuel à miglos dias canal qui va devoir
voilà les affronter les mener à bien
qui est il cet homme c'est un civil donc
il ya une soixantaine d'années qui n'est
après la révolution
un ingénieur de formation qui a été
lui même je dirais je dirais très très
au fait de du monde holly 13 très
intéressés par la question culture de
musique
son épouse est elle-même dirige
l'institut en partir de deux questions
de formation culturelle
il est lui même amateur de musique en
particulier de des pics s il est
toujours là toujours son portable donc
il est très moderne ça dans sa façon
d'être
salle très pragmatique nomme très
concret un homme très prudent qui
s'impliquent dans les dossiers et depuis
qu'il est président il a vraiment suivi
les différents dossiers et il a réussi
dans un profil je lirai très différente
ses prédécesseurs de manière très très
calme de poser des problèmes sans langue
de bois sans discours idéologique
particulier et en essayant d'être au
plus proche du terrain
alors évidemment l'élite travail de plus
en plus d'une manière collégiale
il s'est probablement une des
modifications majeures depuis la
nouvelle constitution il ya un premier
ministre aussi et il ya aussi une
volonté grâce aussi d'une diplomatie
cubaine qui est extrêmement
professionnelle et très aguerris face à
je dirais une contrainte américaine
nord-américaine depuis 60 ans qui est
effectivement est particulièrement dur
et en particulier dans la période
récente avec les 250 mesures à le départ
par treuil et cet embargo qui perdure et
qui est une anomalie dans le monde
international
car au fond rien ne pourra vraiment
considérablement évolué sur le plan
intérieur à cuba en tout cas par rapport
à au système économique et politique
tant que la normalisation avec des états
unis noté réponse est qu'il dépende de
conditions la levée de l'embargo mais
qui dépend de la levée de l'embargo
c'est qui qui dépend du congrès puisque
vous savez c'est une loi menant aux
états unis pour le mandat pour il ya un
deuxième élément c'est la restitution de
la base
delaveau qui est une anomalie est une
portion de territoire cubaine unissant
de templeuve et projets sur le
territoire cubain est évidemment cuba
peut s'appuyer sur un réseau
international extrêmement début le pays
la solidarité internationale les pays
évidemment à bolivarien c'est à dire les
pays régionaux nicaragua venezuela en
particulier et des grands pays comme la
russie la chine l'inde la turquie là
l'essentiel des pays africains
l'essentiel des paysages ya tic auxquels
s'ajoutent aussi un accord cadre de
coopération politique avec l'union
européenne
donc je dirais que cuba n'est d'aucune
manière
seule sur la scène internationale merci
stéphane invite ski président du conseil
d'orientation stratégique des hautes
études de l'amérique latine spécialiste
de cuba d'avoir été avec nous